ليست روسيا طرفا في نظام روما الاساسيه
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وليست ملزمه
بالتعاون معها في مثل هذه الحاله الجو ولو
عاده لتشكيل محاكم متخصصه بقرار من مجلس
الامن حيث تخول الماده الحاديه والاربعون
من ميثاق الامم المتحده لمجلس الامن
السلطه استعمال شده تدابير لانفاذ
قراراتها وينشئ المجلس بانتظام هيئات
فرعيه لدعم او تنفيذ تلك التدابير وقد
تضمنت تلك الهيئات محاكم دوليه عن جرائم
خطيره بموجب القانون الانساني الدولي او
في قضايا طلبه الحكومات مساعده المجلس في
التحقيق فيها او محاكمه المسؤولين عنها
مثل المحكمه الدوليه
عن العباده الجماعيه التي ارتكبت في
رواندا عام 94 هناك عقبه كبيره تتمثل في
ان روسيا عضو دائما في مجلس الامن
وبالتالي ستستخدم حق النقض الفيتو لعدم
صدور مثل هذا القرار